[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Сіверщина
Безводівка]
З плато Безводівка витікає три річки...
[Олександр Кликавка,
автор проекту «Безводівка»]
...Іченька, що протікає через місто Ічня,
один з притоків річки Смош
і на півдні — річка Безводівка.
На честь цієї річки було названо
село Безводівка.
Але сама курганна група,
яка колись складалася з восьми об'єктів,
називається «Роблениці».
Залишилося їх зараз чотири,
багато було зруйновано в період
активної розробки земель.
Деякі кургани мають конічну форму.
Деякі з них мають форму майдана,
яка дуже поширена в Полтавській області, Дніпропетровській.
Це вал, який оточує яму,
і від нього відходить одна чи дві пари «вусів» —
бокових валів.
Північно-східний курган
направлений чітко на схід сонця
в день літнього сонцестояння 22 червня.
І там навіть видно виїмку,
через яку спостерігали схід сонця.
Науковці говорять, що ці кургани належать
кочовим племенам ІІ тис. до н.е.
Тобто, їм щонайменше 3,5-4 тисячі років.
Але кочовим племенам будувати такі
потужні архітектурні споруди
було б не дуже зручно.
Тож це повинні були бути осілі племена.
Народ, який жив на цій території,
певно хлібороби, які слідкували
за рухом небесних світил,
вели календар.
Бо треба сіяти вчасно культури,
вчасно їх збирати
і вести свій життєвий цикл
відповідно до «космічних циклів».
Я вивчав старі карти ХІХ сторіччя,
«трьохверстовки» Шуберта,
і просто натрапив
на цікаву групу умовних позначок.
Виникло питання: що це може бути?
На це питання з'явилося
багато відповідей,
які вишуковувалися в цікаву теорію,
що це — обсерваторія.
Древня, астрономічна обсерваторія.
На зразок англійського Стоунхенджу,
на зразок Аркаїму в Челябінській області.
Зараз обсерваторія — це наукова установа,
в якій є телескоп.
Він дозволяє спостерігати за зірками, сонцем,
місяцем, іншими небесними об'єктами.
Тут телескопу немає,
але є інший інструмент: горизонт.
На ньому дуже добре позначати зміщення
точок сходу і заходу небесних світил.
Ці точки знаходяться на далекій відстані,
для того, щоб мати дуже високу точність.
В давні часи
наука, філософія, релігія
були ще не розділені.
Вони були в сукупності, зв'язані.
Навіть якщо курган був точкою візирування,
він також міг бути місцем поховання
якогось видатного діяча чи астронома.
Вперше я сюди приїхав в 2012 році.
Тут була кукурудза метрів зо 2 висотою.
З дороги курганів не було видно.
Я пробирався до них крізь хащі кукурудзи.
І тільки з кургану зміг оцінити
масштаби усього комплексу.
Чому обсерваторія?
Тому що це місце для спостереження
за небесними світилами.
В центрі був курган —
робоче місце спостерігача.
На тому кургані стояли люди
і дивилися на горизонт,
чекаючи появи небесного світила.
Той курган має діаметр близько 30 м.
Це співрозмірно діаметру
усього Стоунхенджа —
його кам'яне коло 32 метри.
Розумієте, наскільки за масштабами Безводівка
перевершує свого англійського колегу.
Це коло ближніх візирів,
воно має в діаметрі десь 185 метрів.
Цих курганів було близько 40 штук,
залишилося 13.
Та навіть ті, що залишилися, вони в небезпеці,
оскільки охоронна зона, що передбачена законом «Про охорону культурної спадщини»,
на жаль, відсутня.
Сільськогосподарські машини, плуги
впритул підходять до курганів
і щороку вони їх руйнують,
кургани осипаються.
Потрібно, щоб закон нарешті запрацював.
Потрібно, щоб курганна група «Роблениці»
і сама обсерваторія «Безводівка»
набули статусу
археологічної пам'ятки
міжнародного значення.
Людей, що тут жили,
цікавив не лише «хліб насущний».
Вони піднімали голову,
дивилися на зірки,
дивилися на сонце,
вивчали закономірності.
Вони бачили, що все це рухається
в небесній сфері не просто так.
Відповідно до цього вони створювали
свої міфи, казки, календарі.
Кожен камінь Стоунхенджу можна порівняти
з ось таким земляним насипом в Безводівці.
Вони виконують одні й ті самі функції:
позначити, де сходить і заходить сонце чи місяць.
Стоунхендж приваблює сотні тисяч туристів.
Їх приваблює містика, таємниця,
історія, що закладена в тих каменях.
У нас є такий же об'єкт,
який можна досліджувати,
про який можна розповідати
і вдома, і закордоном.
Треба запрошувати сюди людей,
розповідати про нашу історію,
робити це цікаво і яскраво.
[Рік потому]
Цьогоріч, вперше за 100 років,
кургани Безводівки мають охоронну зону.
Нарешті плуги відступили
на 5-7 метрів від підніжжя кургану.
Я хочу подякувати користувачу цих земель
за цей жест, який показує,
що він поважає не лише закони України,
але й нашу історичну спадщину.
Коли рік тому приїжджала
команда Ukraїner на Безводівку,
я пообіцяв Богданові Логвиненко,
що через 2 роки
довкола кожного кургану Безводівки
буде охоронна зона.
Пройшов рік —
і зона уже є.
[автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[аператори
Павло Пашко, Марія Теребус]
[продюсерки
Ольга Шор, Наталка Панченко]
[режисер
Микола Носок]
[монтажерка
Юлія Балка]
[музика
Blooms Corda, Marsbeing]